pour en débattre nous sommes ce soir
avec bruno pomart ancien policier du
raid bonsoir et carnon de 16 avocat au
barreau de paris bonsoir à vous merci
beaucoup à tous les deux d'être en
direct sur rt france question à vous
d'abord bruno pomart vous qui êtes
ancien policier du raid et donc jamais
filmé puisqu'à visage notre visage est
toujours couvert vous porter des
cagoules
est ce que vous vous comprenez le projet
de loi sur la sécurité globale et son
article 24 en particulier oui mais je le
comprends tout à fait j'ai d'abord
j'étais crs j'ai commencé crs mais il y
avait pas ces mouvements de foule et
hyper hostile comme on le voit
maintenant à partir du mouvement gilet
jaune et puis tout ce qu'on voit
actuellement est ce qu on a vu encore
aujourd'hui à travers votre vos images
c'est vrai que cet article 24 la
bienvenue pour les policiers qui ont
besoin d'être protégés dans cette
société qui devient de plus en plus
violente je pense que ça n'a pas échappé
aux à ceux qui sont systématiquement
opposée à cette société de l'orb que
doit être notre pays sinon ça serait la
chienlit et je crois que c'est important
je crois qu'on arrive à protéger nos
policiers d'une façon tout à fait
objective et cette loi effectivement qui
est en train de s'assoupir puisqu'il va
y avoir le conseil constitutionnel
encore derrière qui va avoir son mot à
dire mais je pense que c'est une une
bonne chose pour assurer la sécurité des
policiers parce que je le rappelle quand
même que près de sept mille cinq cents
policiers ont été quand même un blessé 7
ces dernières années c'est on a
quasiment triplé le nombre depuis une
quinzaine d'années ce qui est
catastrophique pour nos forces de
l'ordre blessés en cours de
manifestations vous aider surtout un
instant de deux choses blesser voire
tuer effectivement soit agressé tout
simplement de leur travail par par des
gens qui les ont reconnus sur à travers
les réseaux sociaux puisque les réseaux
sociaux vous savez est un vecteur c'est
intéressant des besoins sociaux ya plein
de choses intéressantes et il ya il ya
beaucoup d'éléments qui sont comment
dire subversif et qui risque qui liste
qui risque pardon à d'entacher la
crédibilité et surtout la sécurité de
vos policiers au jour le jour
le problème car bond de 16 c'est ce que
ce sont les gens
liste qui sont particulièrement visés
par cet article 24 puisque ça rajoute un
délit à la loi de 1881
or il me sens que en tant que
journaliste on est plutôt raisonnable
d'ailleurs il avait il avait compris
lorsqu'on avait demandé à flouter les
militaires à l'époque pour des raisons
de sécurité et les rédactions avaient
joué le jeu est-ce que c'est cet article
24 est justifiée selon vous car ban de
non je rejoins de cieux pommard sur le
besoin de garantir la sécurité des
forces de l'ordre et de tout citoyen en
france d'ailleurs
et le problème n'est pas nouveau mais il
a été effectivement amplifié par les
réseaux sociaux la question que pose
l'article 24 en matière de liberté
d'expression et en matière de liberté
d'informer et donc d'être informé ses
qui vient restreindre dans un cadre tout
à fait flou juridiquement la possibilité
de poursuivre assure une notion très
vague et celle de la tension
malveillants alors d'abord l'attention
malveillantes
elle existe déjà dans notre arsenal
juridique c'est c'est même une des unes
des caractéristiques pour pouvoir
rentrer en voie de condamnation qui
permettent de qualifier une infraction
mais en l'espèce qu'est ce qui se passe
avec ce mécanisme juridique et et la loi
qui a été votée hier c'est qu'on inverse
la charge de la preuve
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où
poursuit ce n'est plus au procureur de
la république de prouver l'intention
malveillante 16 à la personne prévenus
devant le tribunal correctionnel de s'en
défendre
et c'est là que on introduit un élément
qui est de nature à frustrer le
journaliste parce que exposés à un
risque pénal il risque de s'auto
censurer et est bien l'objectif est
poursuivi dans cette loi est bien la
censure ça n'a jamais produit une
information de qualité et l'information
de qualité
c'est la première condition de la
liberté d'informer on le voit d'ailleurs
bruno pomart dayan
journaliste meriem l'arrivée était en
train de filmer une interpellation dans
la rue sur la voie publique et on lui
demande de ne plus filmer on a le droit
de filmer la loi ne l'interdît pas cet
article 24 ce qui est interdit c'est de
diffuser sans flouter par la suite
est ce que finalement ça ce n'est pas
aussi un peu de pouvoirs supplémentaires
aux policiers comment comme on l'avait
fait je crois que écouté que lorsque je
vois les images de tout à l'heure et
votre collègue madame laribi qui a été
interpellé mais mise en garde par par la
police je crois que c'est d'abord ça
s'est fait tout naturellement
ils sont dans un moment il faut le
comprendre en même temps on a extrait
les policiers puisque vous prenez cette
scène bien précises où vous avez une
cinquantaine de black blocs ou je ne
sais pas où tout est sûrement d'extrême
gauche qui viennent évidemment tout
casser les policiers à ce moment là sont
très tendues et vous doutez bien que
lorsqu'il ya un ordre de dispersion
effectivement si le demain de
journalistes et ils l'ont fait à votre à
votre collègue je pense de façon
peut-être un peu stricte sûrement
verbalement je l'entends mais voilà ça
c'est fait dans un consensus là damas a
accusé le coup comme on dit est parti je
pense que ça fait partie du du moment
que vivent les policiers lancés dans ces
moments tendus que sur les
manifestations et ça il faut se remettre
dans le contexte à chaque fois pour bien
le comprendre
le dire le sur un plateau de télé comme
je le fais comme le fait monsieur
l'avocat
c'est vrai que c'est toujours simple de
regarder sous le spectre du juste delà
de la loi
effectivement mais moi je me remets
toujours dans le côté j'ai été serré
c'est j'ai vu ce que c'était les
manifestations certes qui était beaucoup
moins violentes que maintenant c'est
vrai que parfois c'est très compliqué
croyez moi pour les policiers de faire
du discernement à 100% sur de telles
manifestations
je vous en prie monsieur carbon voulait
réagir
oui merci et s'il ya quand même une
grande une grande limite à apporter
al'excuse qui est donnée à la police
d'évacuer elle des journalistes après un
ordre de dispersion
d'abord lui il n'était pas
reconnaissable donc rien n'empêchait de
contenu et de filmer et le
téléspectateur a le droit d'être
informés de la réalité des heurts entre
les policiers et ceux que vous
fier moi je n'en sais rien je n'ai pas
vu de black blocks je n'ai pas entendu
aux informations qu'il y en avait pour
tous les goûts
disposez-vous peut-être en disposez vous
que dans le jeu n'est pas mais quoi
qu'il en soit précisément america
méritait peut-être d'être filmés pour
pouvoir être informés et ça ce qui est
regrettable c'est que les forces de
l'ordre sont formés pour agir
précisément avec discernement monsieur
coma contrairement à ce qu'il y ait du
sexe certainement difficile le maintien
de l'ordre mais toute la noblesse de la
mission qui est confiée aux forces de
l'ordre
c'est précisément d'agir avec
discernement ferry discernement n'y
at-il pas une contradiction monsieur
pommard puisque 10 septembre 2020 gérald
darmanin interdit aux policiers de
mettre des cagoules pendant les
manifestations
or ça aurait été plus simple justement
qu'ils en mettent et qu'on interdise pas
justement à la diffusion pour pour
filmer justement des scènes lors de
manifestations il n'y a pas de raison
que les fonctionnaires ont des kaboul
parce qu d'ailleurs on leur a reproché à
ça c'est un petit peu façon black block
commander rien de cacher le visage donc
fait qui le mal miss l'intérieur a
demandé de d'enlever les cagoules orbi
pour évidemment les groupes
d'intervention ça c'est un autre sujet
donc je pense qu'à ce sur ce sujet là ya
pas d n'y a pas de discussion à voir la
seule chose moi que je souhaite vraiment
appuyé dans ce débat c'est c'est encore
une fois que nos policiers puissent être
protégés et de dos ne pas être mis en
pâture dans les réseaux sociaux où leur
vie est réellement en danger et croyez
moi
de nombreux collègues que je connais et
avec qui je suis souvent en contact ont
dû pour certaines des ménages et voir
changer de lieu de résidence voix
trouver des mutations nouvelles pour
vous réchauffer à la même vie que public
voire à la vindicte de cette héroïne
donc je pense qu'il ya une véritable
nécessité pour protéger nos policiers de
prendre des dispositions comme celles
qui ont été faites par le gouvernement
et saluant les journalistes comprennent
aisément cardon de 16 les
les ong comme amnesty international dit
ce que ça pourrait conduire à davantage
d'interpellations et de violence est ce
que c'est la crainte aussi qu'on peut
avoir avec cet article 24
non je crois pas que les forces de
l'ordre aient la volonté de se prémunir
pour pouvoir devenir plus violente que
certains le sont les les violences
policières existent mais elles ne sont
pas le fait général des forces de
l'ordre par contre ce sur quoi
j'aimerais attirer votre attention
c'est que c'est quand même le ministère
de l'intérieur qui a donné aux syndicats
de police ce gage et que par conséquent
il ya une partie de la police qui se mue
de serviteurs de l'état en groupes de
pression et c'est ça qui n'est pas
acceptable c'est à dire quand même temps
l'article 22 généralise l'utilisation
des drones l'article 22 de la même loi
qui contrevient à toutes les règles de
la commission nationale informatique et
libertés de la captation d'image ce
qu'ils avaient déjà commencé avec la
vidéosurveillance est en train de se
généraliser et dans le même temps où on
généralise la possibilité de filmer dans
le même temps on interdit aux citoyens
de filmer également eh bien ça ce n'est
pas acceptable
si vous voulez années et ça n'est pas
équitable d'un point de vue citoyen et
ça n'est pas fondée juridiquement et
comme le disait monsieur pommard
l'examen par le conseil constitutionnel
de la loi sera à cet égard très
intéressante de même que les débats au
sénat monsieur pommard n'aurait-il pas
fallu plus tôt sanctionner la diffusion
ou est-ce que c'est trop tard de
sanctionner après coup écoutez laissons
faire le conseil constitutionnel encore
une fois ne faisons pas la loi avant les
juristes et autres on n'est pas là pour
ça et pas plus les associations de
défense des droits de l'homme et autres
mais je pense que le monsieur carbone 16
a pas très bien parlé sur le début de
son intervention concernant le le fait
que les policiers doivent être protégés
doivent se donner tous les moyens
effectivement de pouvoir
comment dire visionnez les images quand
c'est nécessaire mais encore une fois
nous sommes pas dans une dictature je
pense que monsieur l'a rappelé à
l'instant on est quand même dans un pays
des droits le pays des droits de l'homme
le pays où on fait on peut se permettre
de faire beaucoup de choses on l'a vu
malheureusement à travers les manifs de
gilet jaune qui étaient des
manifesations in organisé et qui ont
créé deux groupes de grosse
problématique et qui ont amené
malheureusement parfois des policiers
peut-être pas à commettre certains actes
délictueux tout simplement mais il faut
savoir le temps que ces policiers ont
été ont été sanctionnés malgré ce qu'on
peut dire à travers l'igpn également les
tribus long puisqu'il ya près de 2000
fonctionnaires
cette année 2040 précisément en 2019 qui
ont été sanctionnés par le ministère
l'intérieur et par la justice pour des
faits connus donc on ne peut pas dire
que les policiers sont absous de leduc
de tout
comment dire de tout quoi comment de
cette responsabilité de tout le
responsable merci d'ailleurs on a le
droit de filmer leur numéro
d'immatriculation de tafer le et rio le
fameux s'éteint c'est un matricule de
sept chiffres qui permet d'identifier le
policier et de remonter évidemment
jusqu'à son service puis c'est un numéro
d'identification et organisationnelles
qui permet effectivement de savoir qui
est ce monsieur donc non prénomme etc
etc l affectation il a donc s'il ya
nécessité effectivement à l'occasion de
dunes de la justice que la justice se
présente pour pour effet comment dire
mettre en accusation en policier il y
aura possibilité de le faire et je pense
pas qu'ils aient volonté du ministère de
l'intérieur de cacher ce dans des sens
nous ne sommes pas dans des dictatures
d'amérique du sud je rappelle qu'à
rebonds et deux sèvres est d'accord avec
ça ça va être simplifié ou pas le
travail des détenus atteints mais non
mais non mais non mais non je crois que
précisément quand on crée une infraction
du simple fait de capter l'image lors
pas uniquement les diffuser de façon
malveillants ça oui
une possibilité à la police précisément
d'empêcher que la preuve soit constitué
quand elle même
outre pas cette fonction en commettant
des violences donc si vous voulez je
crois que là-dessus
ce texte est un texte qui est fait
par monsieur darmanin qui veut complaire
aux forces de police
il est ministre de l'intérieur est
normal mais ça ne doit pas outrepasser
le droit commun or là on est en train de
faire glisser des dispositions de l'état
d'exception dans le droit commun et sans
qu'il y ait de réaction majeure 1
vous voyez bien que les manifestations
n'attire pas les foules c'est peut-être
une erreur ou confinement mais ça
s'inscrit dans un mouvement général du
législateur de diminution des libertés
publiques
d'une façon générale on vient de
s'entretenir avec monsieur poma sur la
liberté d'informer et et puis aussi la
liberté individuelle puisque on
généralise avec cet article 22 lusage
des drones et là encore avec un travail
incomplet du législateur puisque on
encadre même pas la généralisation de
l'utilisation des drones mais dites moi
si je me trompe
on peut filmer un policier qui a un acte
malveillant vers un manifestant pour le
coup ça passe pas sous le coup des
sanctions puisqu'il n'y aura pas
d'intentions malveillantes et ce sera
pour montrer quelque chose d'un format
tiff mais madame tout dépend de ce que
vous allez en faire et vous l'envoyez au
procureur de la république
très bien mais imaginons que le
procureur de la république lui qui
travaille avec sous son autorité des
policiers donc il ya une réticence
gerhard schick et naturel poursuivra
monsieur camara cité les exemples déjà
nombreux de violence qui ont été
poursuivis mais il y en a eu beaucoup
moins que de gilet jaune et avec
beaucoup moins de célérité donc si vous
voulez gala un rapport de force qui
n'est pas le même
imaginons que le même procureur de la
république décide de ne pas poursuivre
pour une raison x ou y est vous le
diffuser sur les réseaux sociaux d or
voilà il ya eu un acte répréhensible
commis à l'occasion d'une manifestation
et cet acte n'a donné lieu à aucune
suite si vous le dites et que vous le
diffuser sur les réseaux sociaux pour
dénoncer l'absence de poursuites
vous pouvez et quand vous êtes poursuivi
ce sera à vous trouvez que ce n'était
pas malveillantes c'est ça qui est
démente vous voulez c'est la juste et
c'est un lapsus très amusant qu'a commis
d'ailleurs monsieur darmanin quand il a
été interviewé par madame sonia mabrouk
il parlait précisément la version de la
charge de la preuve de sauf qu'à ce
moment là il s'est rendu compte que
c'était pas dans son intérêt de le dire
mais c'était trop tard
allez-y monsieur wipo mari m un dernier
mot très court excusez moi mais un même
temps de la justice doit être revu par
la justice par le procureur elle leur
pas être rendues par les réseaux sociaux
et par ceux qui diffusent des images et
qui considèrent que ces images sont les
images de violence sinon il ya plus de
justice dans ce pays excusez moi enfin
les journalistes ont un peu traîné au
parfois aussi à à révéler salutaire aux
affaires on parle bien évidemment pas du
citoyen lambda mais du travail des
espaces systématique de madame des
journées soit 6 merci beaucoup en tout
cas à tous les deux d'avoir participé à
ce monsieur